hi everyone it has been amazing to hear
what everyone's working on I've learning
a lot from uh all these projects as well
and I'm here to give you a little bit of
spicy history about the meta cartel um
what we've been doing in the ecosystem
of ethereum for about seven years now
and um what we're moving towards now as
a global node in this remote State
Network so um back in 2018 the was
formed by going direct to community this
is a photo of all of us at um one of the
earlier meetups in Prague uh back in the
status days um just before Devcon we
went from Community creation to Capital
formation um super fast um we started uh
with the people first bringing all the
people together having conversations and
discussions um doing meetups uh went
into a metat transaction research group
quickly evolved into a grant-giving
organization realizing that people need
funds in this ecosystem to be building
daps and experiments um some of those
projects went on to become super
successful companies raising funds all
across the ecosystem and providing
things for defi governance all kinds of
stuff um a really high bar for entry it
was 10 eth per member so over the last
like four or five years we've
accumulated 140 members under that
spectrum and the current value of grants
that we've given away is a million and a
half dollars and these are all no
strings attached grants uh that go to
people who are building and creating and
experimenting inside of ethereum it's
all about the grants that we do we spent
a lot of time uh working with folks
doing mentorship um our grants portal is
open right now at medac cartel. org and
that is how I got started in this
ecosystem is helping people who are
applying for Grants find their way
through the process um um get their
wallets logged in get their funds
transferred and um get these funds out
to people in the ecosystem um a little
history about uh mik mik da you may have
heard of mik the god that you have to
sacrifice your babies to uh so we we
doubled down on that Meme um mik the
original da that was helping to fund
layer to ethereum research started by
mean solomani um my good friend Peter
Pan was rejected from mik da so he said
I'm going to Fork it and he created
metac cartel so the first founder of
this Dow created metac cartel um the
mullik Dow framework has the rage quit
feature which allows anyone to leave the
Dow at any point with their proportional
ownership so if you don't like a vote
even during grace period you can exit
the Dow now uh Dow house is the
framework that we created that allows
anyone to create uh their own Dow today
secures $100 million in community
treasuries memes um our community is
driven on memes so we the spicy chili
man has been our um our our mascot for a
long long time uh he went on and he's
lived all over the place from shirts
socks hats um but it's a mimetic filter
for community members people who are
aligned with this kind of don't take
yourselves too seriously we're all like
you know having a laugh here but we're
creating cool stuff and experimenting as
well so the current phase of what we're
doing gutting the chil not everything
lives forever Dows are meant to die as
well so currently gutting the chili
looks like spreading uh funds out to
smaller groups we call them subd Dows
that have um their own little um theme
or thesis for what they want to be
funding so we give funds to a group of
five to 10 people and they go and spread
it across the ecosystem new novel
projects um funding the next generation
of
Builders um um that's where the events
came in for me personally uh I don't
have a computer science background I
have a Hospitality background I love
people I love food I love Gatherings
things like this um so we started
running mcon which is our own Dow
conference hosted in Denver for two
years we did one in 2021 and one in 2022
350 people at start 800 people at the
next and mcon 3 who knows um we haven't
decided when we're going to do it or
what what where it will be hosted um but
when the community calls we'll come at
answering uh the whole goal was to get
people together to get them out of their
heads a little bit and in more of a fun
and collaborative environment so we
hosted the last one in a a high school
building took over the Hall High School
and did workshops and classes and then
dodgeball on the
lawn um we've run meetups and events all
around the world um there's even more
more than this these are my early slides
um but one place that I've enjoyed
spending time and doing meetups is in
Costa Rica we have been going down to
Costa Rica for 3 years running now and
we decided after the last mcon where we
were all so stressed out and so tired
from having conversations and
discussions and networking that like
what if we could just get like 50 or 60
of our best friends together and go
somewhere and take over a space and have
cool conversations do some excursions
eat good food and have conversations
about what the future of this movement
looks like so that brought us to co
Costa Rica um Costa Rica is all about
Vibes it's about Connections um it is a
self- selected group of people who are
willing to spend 8 to 10 days in a
tropical environment and co-h housee uh
co-work and co-organize it's completely
unconference so you show up and we
organize uh what you want to do and the
conversations you want to be having
together what it what came from metac
Camp is metac campus we've been renting
event centers and Retreat centers for 3
years now for these events and we
decided we thought more what if we could
have our own space built from the ground
up um how would that better benefit the
members and the experiences that they're
having there so this idea was floated at
the last metac campus and Bas or at the
last meta Camp event and basically I've
been running with the support of our our
core
team searches for land ideas
inspirations for how we could develop
this Center and make it something that
really enhances people's experience when
they come down and spend time with us
we're all about deeper connections
forging cohesion um and aligning uh a
really curated community of people to do
more
together so where are we now we're
building metac campus we bought 5 acres
in Costa Rica on uh the Pacific coast in
plra it's a beautiful um Community uh
that doesn't even have a road to it so
we like it um it's it's it's not too
hard to get to 90 minutes from the
airport and a quick and easy flight for
most major hubs uh we have really
ambitious plans for what we want the
community to to be and to look like but
we're trying to keep it small we're not
thinking about scaling all over the
world or having properties everywhere we
want to do this property well from the
beginning um we've got support and we've
got um input and say from the community
so we're really trying to develop in the
open and adhere to what the desires of
the community is and that's over 150
people who have come to our events
throughout the past few years and then a
uh the segment of those who are actually
putting Capital into this so all this
money has been raised from the community
and we've just been soliciting ideas and
feedback um we believe that this is a
central node in the movement H towards a
network State and we were super excited
and happy to like be sharing this this
information with others and like
collaborating with other projects that
we're meeting on this journey um just
want to double down on Costa Rica
specifically if you haven't been it is
beautiful um we think it's a super
stable place um politically and also
climate wise uh being near the beach is
really good for People's Health and
wellbeing we're not at the water which
is ideal for us with uh climate change
situations but there's a bunch of
benefits for why you choose Costa Rica
um and coming down there we have had
some of the most amazing transformative
experiences um in relation to the locals
in relation to learning and sharing with
folks who have been down there and
building either Eco Resorts or Retreats
for the past 20 years and we found all
the resources that we need to be able to
grow this uh this project and scale
sustainably um with the desires and the
intentions of our community so you you
can see this little graph here it's got
all of the kind of like key points um
that people are most interested in in
our community and it's it's it's it's
various uh because this is not just
about the tech it's not just about the
people it's about all the interests
bringing the full human to the picture
we find that a lot of the traditional
conferences they want to focus on the
tech um on what's being built and they
want to go you know very much into the
details we want to bring the human into
the picture what are you what are you
about what are you excited about what do
you want to build and how can we help
you and align you with other creators
who are on board with with what you want
to build as well so that's a little bit
about where we're at today and where
we've come from in the past metac campus
is really um about culture first uh and
community over
everything that's it um my name is yayer
if you're interested in learning more
about metac camp or metac campus hit me
up after
this